is a traditional healer using ancestral
practices he calls on the spirits to
bring Victory to cameroon's national
football team National Night Team should
win he says it's the extra spark the
indomitable Lions as they're known need
before their first game when this fire
burn like that you see the Smoke On Fire
go up the the spirits the inhale
the smoke it's like telephone
they will come
John says several players have been
Consulting traditional healers ahead of
the World Cup in Qatar and it's right
the old magic
any Village has its own Magic
any region has your own magic so when
all these magicians they become together
then they begin to pray for the sources
for the sunsets for the lion nobody can
drop them down
in Cameroon as in many African countries
natural medicine plays an important role
in remedies that are believed to enhance
performance are popular among athletes
the tinctures are made from plants found
in the forest and are available at local
markets abas Ali A former defender in
his village team started selling them
after he suffered an e strain the same
injury that is preventing Striker
sajamane from playing in Senegal's
opening game
this vendor says that he has the
appropriate remedies for the football
star sadio Mane who's suffering from an
injury he just needs to come to this
stall here you have all sorts of powders
and liquids coming from the sacred
cameroonian forests and he says if that
doesn't work then he needs to wear one
of these the object is meant to protect
him from further injury and the vendor
says bring him luck when he comes to
sports Superstition are plentiful
Maradona carried the same Rosary at each
game England's Gary lineker changed
shirts at half time if the match wasn't
going in his favor Cristiano Ronaldo
always steps onto the pitch right foot
first
cameroon's manager has denied
approaching Black magicians but there is
no stopping fans from doing all they can
to ensure the indomitable lions live up
to their nickname
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera yonde